>>> I WANT TO EXPRESS MYSELF
BECAUSE I'M YOUNG AT HEART AND I
WANT TO SHOW IT.
>> AND I WANT TO LOOK AS YOUNG
AS I FEEL.
>> BUT ANTI-AGING CREAMS IN HAIR
DYES HAVE HARMFUL CHEMICALS THAT
JUST AREN'T ME.
>> BECAUSE I'M ECO FRIENDLY AND
A LITTLE FUNKY TOO.
>> WHAT DO WE DO?
>> SOUNDS LIKE YOU NEED GRAY
ADULT PIGTAILS.
>> THE NUMBER ONE HAIRSTYLE FOR
WHIMSICAL WOMEN OF A CERTAIN
AGE.
>> WHETHER YOU'RE A PUPPETEER, A
PET PSYCHIC --
>> OR SOMEONE'S AUNT'S
THERAPIST'S WIFE.
>> YOU NEED A HAIR STYLE THAT
SAYS, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT ME FOR YEARS AFTER
MEETING ME FOR FIVE MINUTES.
>> BECAUSE YOU'RE UNIQUE.
>> YOU LOVE ART.
>> AND YOU WANT PEOPLE TO SEE
YOU AND THINK, "GOT IT."
>> so GRAB TWO ELASTICS AND
CHANGE YOUR LIFE WITH GRAY ADULT
PIGTAILS.
>> BECAUSE YOU NEVER STOP
SMOKING POT.
WHY SHOULD YOUR HAIR?
>> PAIR IT WITH --
>> A CRANBERRY'S T-SHIRT.
>> CHILDREN'S TUTU.
>> THIS BAG.
>> BEN IMHAT.
>> RASTA HAT.
>> YOU WISH YOU COULD BE THIS
WHIMSICAL.
I LOOK HOW INCENSE SMELLS.
>> I HAVE A BOYFRIEND WHO COMES
OVER ONCE A WEEK.
HE LIVES IN THE WOODS, KEEPS
BONGOS IN HIS TRUCK, AND IS VERY
MUCH A SCULPTOR.
>> HEY, PUSSYCAT.
>> AH, RICHARD, BABY.
HOW DID YOUR SCULPTING GO TODAY?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
DO THESE SHARP, RUSTY BEAUTIES
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION?
>> OH, RICHARD, BABY.
YOU'RE A GENIUS.
I LOVE YOUR MIND EVEN MORE THAN
YOUR BODY.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE SHE LOVES?
MY GRAY ADULT PIG TAIL.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THEY'RE NOT JUST FOR LADIES.
THEY'RE FOR RICHARD, TOO.
>> YOU WERE MARRIED TO THAT GOLF
PLAYER FOR WAY TOO LONG.
YOU WANT TO ATTRACT THE RIGHT
KIND OF MAN.
>> wHEN I PUT MY GRAY HAIR WAY
UP HIGH AND IMMEDIATELY GOT A
BOYFRIEND.
>> ME TOO.
SAME ONE.
>> YEAH, WE'RE ALL DATING
RICHARD.
>> HE'S LIKE IF A GUY WAS MAGIC.
>> NINE YEARS AGO WE MET AT A
WHITE BUDDHIST TEMPLE FOR
SWINGERS.
>> HE'S A FREAK FOR THE GRAY
ADULT PIGTAILS.
>> YEAH, WHAT CAN'T I SAY?
CAN'T RIDE A BIKE WITH NO HANDLE
BARS.
>> OH, RICHARD!
>> WITH ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
PIGGY TAILS?
>> LOOK WHAT I MADE.
IT'S A VERY SHARP METAL GUITAR.
>> WE SHOULD BLOW THE ROOF OFF
THIS PLACE.
LET'S HIT IT.
♪ AND THE SEASONS GO ROUND AND
ROUND ♪
♪ AND THE PAINTED MOLDINGS THEY
GO UP AND DOWN ♪
>> GRAY ADULT PIGTAILS.
BUY THEM AT ANY NATURAL FOOD
HEALTH STORE.
♪♪